[Music]
morning i've come out to the woods
because i want to tell you about a new
electric vehicle that's coming out that
could allow me to be out here without
needing to bring all of this
you see there's a company called rivien
that's starting deliveries of its r1t an
all-electric pickup that you can get
with 400 miles of range and a tent and a
flashlight and a first aid kit and you
can even get it with a kitchen sink it's
aimed at folks who enjoy being outdoors
like me
but it's not the kitchen sink that's
causing a stir you see rivion has
received over 10 billion dollars in
funding since 2019 and a lot of that has
come from amazon that's why we saw bezos
driving one on the way to his space
launch and now rivien has filed for an
ipo while the company hasn't disclosed
the size or price range of its public
offering it's expected to be tens of
billions of dollars to put that into
context the company could have a higher
valuation than industry leader ford even
though rivien is only around a decade
old and he's only just starting to
deliver vehicles so what's driving that
huge valuation and could anything
obstruct rivien's plans well pull up a
chair i'll explain
a big part of rivien's high valuation is
that its evs are primarily aimed at a
hugely popular segment of the auto
market
pickups pickups made up a fifth of us
auto sales in 2020 with ford's f-series
often being the most popular and now
those pickups are going electric what's
more a new breed of automakers like
tesla and lordstown have also developed
ev pickups tesla says its cyber truck
will have a maximum range of around 500
miles and is expected to cost 70 000
doesn't look like anything else
following the tesla playbook rivian
plans on selling direct to consumers and
not through dealerships like ford does
ford is releasing its electric f-150
lightning which the company says will
have a max range of 300 miles and costs
just shy of 50 000
and biden seems to be a fan this
sucker's quick
but most of rivien's competitors won't
be releasing vehicles till next year and
while riview might not be able to
deliver huge volumes this year its r1t
is still set to arrive before its bigger
older rivals and that could sway some
early adopters and give them a seat at
the table another thing that's exciting
investors rivien has major backing from
amazon who have injected millions into
the company and it's placed a big order
with rivian not for those r1ts but
instead for 100 000 electric delivery
vans the investment is part of amazon's
plans to invest in transportation as it
tries to eliminate its carbon footprint
before 2040
but it's not all smooth terrain ahead
for rivian while the company could
deliver its trucks ahead of many of its
rivals it too has been impacted by
supply chain delays and the global chip
shortage in july it announced it was
pushing deliveries back to september and
then there's the issue of where rivens
will be used because rivien don't just
want you to go to the hardware store
they want you to come out here to the
wild
but if an internal combustion engine ran
out of fuel here i could easily hike to
the nearest gas station get some
gasoline and bring some back
you can't really do that with
electricity to get around this rivien
says it's building its own charging
network some of which will be in u.s
national parks with 3 500 fast chargers
at 600 sites by 2023 but it's yet to be
seen if people who are trying to unplug
for the weekend will also be willing to
plug in let alone whether it will appeal
to the traditional pickup market so can
rivien live up to the hype well there
were three million pickups sold in 2020
so even if rivien captures a small part
of that market
it's still enough to keep traditional
automakers on their toes hey if you're
into evs then we've got a great new
video on gm's new cadillac i've left the
link below and if you want to know more
about the future of how we might be
getting from a to b then don't forget to
subscribe catch you later
[Music]